bonjour chers collègues bonjour monsieur
viennent alors moi une première question
qui sur le sujet qui me touche
particulièrement à coeur comment mieux
défendre le secteur de la pêche dans les
outre-mers menacée par le pillage des
ressources et comment mieux structuré
affronter la concurrence des pêcheurs
illégaux c'est un sujet vraiment en tout
cas j'attends des réponses de votre part
d'autant plus que j'ai une année en
chansons viennent d'ailleurs et j'ai une
réunion bas demain demain avec monsieur
le préfet et toute la communauté donc
dépêchez vous pour répondre à votre
question
comment me défendre le secteur de la
pêche dans l'outre-mer avec le pillage
je
témoignerai avec le jure buteau j'étais
la semaine dernière sauf erreur de ma
part en audition avec le conseiller
outre-mer de la république françois de
kelver je crois
qui
effectivement dis tout de suite on a des
enjeux de sécurisation
c'est moi je lui dis de mon point de vue
madame la sénatrice
tant que ces espaces
sont à côté de la france hexagonale
on n'aura jamais les budgets est-ce que
ça devient des budgets en plus aux
dépenses de la france hexagonale si on
ne l'est pas une un regard
d'unis cité comme notre république ne
dit qu'elle est une et indivisible
si on ne dit pas que c'est un sujet de
la france océanique on n'aura jamais les
budgets on n'aura jamais les moyens et
est encore une fois un jeu je vais dire
à des membres de la commission
dans toute famille généralement on
s'occupe de ses enfants et quand on a le
temps on s'occupe des cousins germains
des enfants
peut-être que les autres maires sont
trop les cousins germains pardon si je
pense c'est à dire que d'abord on
s'occupe de l'hexagone et après
budgétairement du reste donc je
répondrai que pour mieux accompagner
je dirais
exploitation de ces espaces qui
appartiennent à la france océanique
il faut arrêter les considérer comme des
dépenses budgétaires additionnelles il
faut arrêter les considère comme des
dépenses de jeu et est donc par
entêtement et par tonna cité par passion
je reviens à mon fait sortons de ce ce
corner outre-mer france hexagonale et
outre-mer france hexagonale france
océanique et nous sommes tous france
en premier lieu je serai sur du
déclaratif
avec ça est ce que ça nous permet
d'aller plus loin je sais pas mais c'est
un début de raisonnement parce que nos
pêcheurs je parle pour ceux de la région
que je connais leurs instruments le race
leurs instruments sont
sont que financier le fait l'anc vous
connaissez comme moi le fair play dont
ils sont que financier après ils vont se
tourner vers l'armée en région qui à ses
patrouilleurs mais avec plein de mission
a assuré donc s'il n'y a pas une
complète u2 et impactent océaniens
nous n'aurons nous n'aurons pas aux
priorités partagées non pas la défense
madame la sénatrice de nos espaces mais
je dire l usage et le et l'utilisation
raisonnée et ambitieuse de nos espaces